[Applause]
is gonna
put it let's start again hello Ohio
[Applause]
thank you for everything you've done
Ohio is so close to my heart my husband
went to Ohio State University I put him
through Ohio State I feel oh wait oh
oh
yeah
my husband actually works for a company
in Ohio and our first home we bought was
in Cleveland so we love this state the
state the state's so near and dear to
our heart and you guys thank you for
being here I I want to thank each and
every one of you for coming out in the
middle of the day and caring enough
about our country to go out and vote and
talk to voters and do all the things
you're going to do
um how many of you feel like you're
better off than you were two years ago
how many of you are feeling the pain of
gas prices inflation and Home Heating
and crime fentanyl raise your hand raise
your hand we're all feeling it we are
all feeling it
country is not going in the right
direction and the Democrats own it they
own it they're not running on the things
they've done they're not running on
their record they're trying to lie to
the American people and pretend that the
things we feel every day aren't real
and it's insulting and the only way you
let people know that they're getting it
wrong is by firing them and that's what
we have to do and so JD and Madison and
Mike dewine and Frank and the pool
ticket in Ohio is going to make sure
that we are standing up as Republicans
for every single ohioan and every single
voter and family in this great state so
you all look great but I have some work
for you okay
between now and election day it's 11
days
you need to go talk to everyone you know
this isn't just a rally this is every
single person back there we need you to
go talk to every person you know your
family members your loved ones your
co-workers the people you go to church
with if you have wronged somebody make
it right
okay
you eat a little Humble Pie and then go
talk about this election because so much
is at stake so much is at stake and so
between now and election day I don't
want you to do anything else I'm a mom
I'm giving you all a permission slip you
can miss every family event
recital every soccer game whatever it is
because that's how important it is we
want a house race in 2020 by six votes
six votes you don't want to wake up the
day after the election and say I didn't
talk to that neighbor and I didn't talk
to that friend because not everybody's
thinking about it at the level we do not
everybody knows that the midterm
election is on November 8th I'll tell
you what I just did my daughter's in
college out in Utah she got her absentee
ballot and she was not returning it so
you know what Mom did I said if you
don't get that ballot in I'm not sending
you rent money
[Applause]
I was not kidding I would not so that
ballot is in okay blackmails okay guys
on the table you all look great you look
handsome and beautiful and well rested
by November 9th I want you all to look
like crap
because you've done every possible thing
you can and I'll be right there with you
because I'm traveling the whole country
I just want to brag on JD Vance I've
known him for a while he's such a great
man he's going to be a great senator for
Ohio and Madison how amazing is she
she's so great
[Applause]
everything you can do between now and
election day and are you excited to take
our country
speaker who is I'm on tour with right
now we're on to take back our country
tour no we're not a band
he would be the lead singer I would be
playing the drums I think but he has
taken over the senatorial committee this
cycle which means he's helping all the
tenant candidates across the country and
he works so hard he never rests if there
was a supplement that we could sell the
Rick Scott supplement we should all be
taking it because he is the most energy
of anybody I know and I love love
working with him please give a big Ohio
welcome to the senator from Florida Rick
Scott
thank you
I'm sure some of you have vacationed or
have a house or no relatives in Florida
so first if you need anything from
Florida call me that's fine it's my
primary job so thank you for coming out
you know I've uh I've had one primary in
three general elections and you're very
appreciative when people come out and
care about these races because you know
we got we've got to take our country
back uh so in what you're doing you're
the reason why we live you know the
candidates have to do their job we have
to raise all this ridiculous amounts of
money but you get the vote out so thank
you for what you're doing Rhonda
McDaniel has done a great job as a
chairperson our chairman of the RNC
so in my race in 18 when I was the only
Republican that won a swing state the
city it was really because of what the
RNC did they worked hard to make sure we
got her vote out and we had to get her
vote out we had to get 4.3 million votes
which was over a million 1.2 million
more votes more than four years earlier
so what they do and what you do it
really makes a difference one person I
want to recognize I don't know if Jane's
been recognized yet but I want to
recognize Jane Timber
foreign
chair she ran a great race and what what
we need to do after these primaries and
primaries are hard on people uh because
we got to come together and James
Cleveland done that to help JD and make
sure we win so thank you Jane for what
you're doing
so this is why this race is so important
I'm the chairman of the national
Republican Central Committee and my what
I've got to do is make sure I do
everything I can to help our candidates
win and we get a majority
right now Chuck Schumer controls
everything on the center
I don't get a vote my vote doesn't
matter
instructor Schumer decides what we vote
on and doesn't give us any amendments
and most of our bills important bills
don't go through committees anymore
which we get no Amendment votes we have
no say at all right and we can even in
50 50 Cent is completely controlled by
the Democrats injection
so think about it think about why we
have to win
if you look at why why JD has to be your
Center let's just go through something
it's a pretty easy
look at gas prices
the Democrats did that
why did the Democrats have done all
these things they said oh they don't
they hate fossil fuel it means you got
high gas prices for poor people and
people on fixed income in my state I got
a lot of people that retired going back
to work
uh we were I was in uh earlier today
Wisconsin with Ron Johnson and some guy
came up before we got his bus he said my
wife just went back to work
because you know there were eight 77
years old people come back to work
they're going to food banks they're
never gone look at food prices I took my
uh my little brother he says I mean he
is he is he's retired he was a super a
principal at school and he works at
register he says it's still hard to make
ends meet with food prices the
temperature have done this it's
intentional what they're doing
look at the border the border is
completely open it's open it is by the
way if you realize if you come across
the border they give you ice restaurant
if they don't know anything about you
and an hour later you can go get on a
commercial flight
my wife and I got we got married when we
were 19 we have grandkids every time I
chilled it talk to them I gotta talk to
him about fentanyl drug problems don't
take anything from somebody else the
Democrats did this
what in the living Village are they
doing so you can go through whether it's
inflation or a woke military or whether
it's the Border I mean this is a simple
equation
we've got to elect JD and we've got to
get a majority we're going to get a
majority I believe I think we're gonna
we're gonna have we're gonna win 52
seats plus but it's really up to you
guys it's it's getting the votes out we
have got to bust our butts to get the
votes out and so we've got every day and
we got to say who can who else can we
get to the polls the door knockers the
people make phone calls or friends all
these things it matters that's how we
win these races and then when we when we
got to govern
and we got to govern the right way we've
got to say we're going to change the
direction of this country back to a
country where everybody every kid I grew
up with a poor family a kid Like Me grew
up a poor family has every reason to
believe they can be anything
that's the country we have to make for
everybody and Jay advances that person
the first time I talked to JD I said you
just tell your story what you went
through
thank God you lived in this country
thank God you had grandparents
she's because you got to live the dream
of this country JD will go to DC and he
will not he will not worry about what a
rail says he'll worry about what Ohioans
want
so it's my distinct card introduce
somebody that I look forward to serving
with yeah JD Vance
if you say something before you clap for
me you might hear what I say uh I want
to say first of all thanks to Rick Scott
and the whole team for for being here at
the nrsc Rana thank you for being here
it's great to see you uh I want to give
a special shout out to Jane timkin for
being here I really appreciate it Jane
really appreciate everything we've done
so and and of course you guys know
better than anybody I'm gonna go fire
Chuck schimmer Madison's gonna fire
dancing
it's sort of yeah it's it's it's amazing
to me how much energy and passion
Madison brings to this race the fact
that she's out campaigning it all you
would never believed she had a baby four
weeks ago and here she is get this fired
up and get us ready to win this race
let's let's talk about the stakes of
this election and let's talk about what
we're really fighting for a lot of you
guys know my story Rick kind of talked
about it a little bit look I'm I'm a
product of the American dream I'm a
product of a country where if you work
hard and play by the rules you can
achieve great things whether you come
from a richer or poor family a black or
a white family and what an incredible
thing it is that it's possible for our
kids to achieve their dreams in this
country that all of us love but I gotta
say the very thing that made it possible
for me to succeed in this country the
very thing that made it possible for me
to become you know a husband and a
father the thing that I really wanted to
do when I was a kid was give my my kids
the things that I didn't have when I was
growing up and that's the way in which
this state in this country has been best
in me but that doesn't happen without
careful investment it doesn't happen
unless we preserve the American dream
into the Next Generation what we're
doing right now ladies and gentlemen
what the leadership of this country is
doing is plundering what our
grandparents and our parents gave us and
it's time on November the 8th to fight
back and take the fight to the Democrats
in Washington DC that's exactly what
we're going to do we have to the country
depends on it
I mean just think about this the law and
order that we cast aside I'm 38 years
old for the first 36 years of my life we
had violent crime going down murders
going down carjacking is going down and
now they're going in the wrong direction
why because our leadership decided to
declare war on the police I think we
ought to declare war on the violent
criminals and let the police go and do
their job right
and Ryan and Joe Biden said that they
would not raise taxes on the middle
class what a joke now it's wrong on its
own terms they raise taxes on the middle
class like four weeks ago with with the
so-called inflation reduction act they
sent 87 000 IRS agents after middle
class Ohioans to collect those tax
increases and even if you ignore that
the inflation that we're experiencing
right now to the tune of six thousand
dollars a year Falls hardest on the
middle class in this state and it's not
because we have any problem in this
country except for bad leadership what's
going on in this country right now is
that we have leaders who shut down our
energy sector leaders who raise taxes
and borrowed and spent too much money
leaders who set violent criminals loose
and leaders who decided to throw open
the gates of the United States Southern
border and I happen to think that's not
leadership that's cowardice let's fire
these guys in a couple of weeks
foreign
County GOP headquarters great to be at
the Madison Jesse Otto GOP headquarters
here but but you know maybe we should
have invited Tim Ryan because he's a
republican now right that's what he says
in all of his TV advertisements yeah we
were with Donald Trump Jr a couple weeks
ago he said he said JD why didn't you
invite Tim Ryan I heard from his TV
commercials he's my biggest fan now
and that is that that is the battle in
our Senate race ladies and gentlemen
we've got to elect our governor our
secretary of state our attorney general
our great Supreme Court Justices Sharon
Kennedy
but in the Senate we have a slightly
different task because we have a
Democrat who is running as far away from
the Democrat Party as he possibly can
and who could blame him right who can
blame him after the last two years of
failed Democrat leadership I saw his
commercial recently where he said he
said that he only agrees with his wife
seventy percent of the time that must be
awkward at home because you agree with
Nancy Pelosi 100 of the time
record says but look here is the problem
this guy is not the moderate that he
pretends to be he is not an independent
voice in Washington DC he's a guy who
bends the knee to Nancy Pelosi and does
what he's told and if we give him a
promotion to the Senate which we're not
going to do he's going to do the exact
same thing with Chuck Schumer and I
happen to think that Tim Ryan you know
he's lived off the government teeth for
long enough let's send him that back to
Youngstown let's force him to get a real
job
thank you
so here here's where I want to close
ladies and gentlemen I've got a job to
do of course it's to get out there to
talk to as many people it's to make sure
that we stay on the airwaves radio TV
digital media so that we can reach those
all-important undecided voters but
here's the thing I'd ask from each and
every one of you go out there and talk
to as many people as possible and tell
them two things number one why you're
voting for me and number two why you're
voting against Tim Ryan as much as the
Democrats have the biggest Super PAC in
the world on their side and of course
I'm talking about the corporate media
that's right we have the people and we
have the truth but that only works if we
get out there and do the work necessary
to get people to the polls to tell them
that truth and if every single one of
you leave here and text or call or or
stop by the house of 10 friends and make
sure they get to the polls and make sure
they vote for me I believe we're going
to win this race and we're going to win
it in a very very convincing fashion so
we've got 10 days 10 days to Sprint to
the finish line and save this country
and I I'd maybe just leave it on on this
note a good friend of mine who's very
influential to me returning to my
Christian faith once told me about a
year and a half ago when I was whining
about the condition this country was in
and I was talking about how Biden was
doing this and Biden was doing that and
Chuck Schumer was doing that and he kind
of snapped me out of it and said JD
despair is a sin I thought a lot about
that the last year and a half because in
this moment ladies and gentlemen we're
not called to despair about this view
this country we're not called to be
depressed about this country we're
called to get in the fight and save it
in 10 days that's exactly what we're
going to do let's get to work
let me get back over to the great
Madison
[Applause]
video for the campaign so I thought what
better time to do it than today while
you guys are all here at our
headquarters so will you join me for
this video yeah yes all right I'm gonna
come here they're going to take it for
this your other way
I brought my twister to help so I'm
going to turn it over to you guys you're
gonna let people know how many days and
get out to vote so just say 11 days get
out your boat sound good okay let's do
it hey everybody we're out here at the
headquarters we are ready and we are so
excited
this is the Republican energy
glossy
[Applause]
what are we gonna
do
it
[Music]
thanks everyone by the way where's James
Hampton
Elementary
[Applause]
foreign